l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur jean leonetti
sur le président mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
s'adresse à vous et j'y associe
l'ensemble des maires des
alpes-maritimes eric ciotti président du
conseil départemental notre département
vous l'avez dit a été gravement touchée
par des intempéries d'une violence sans
précédent dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
en moins d'une heure alors que nous
étions seulement en alerte orange
des pluies torrentielles se sont
abattues sur notre département et plus
particulièrement sur les villes de
cannes de mandelieu d'antibes de biot de
vallauris de villeneuve loubet il s'agit
tout d'abord et nous venons d'observer
une minute de silence d'un drame humain
avec à ce jour
vingt-et-une victimes et nos pensées
premières vont tous envers les familles
en deuil et les dégâts matériels subis
par les villes par les particuliers par
les entreprises sont considérables je
tiens aussi à saluer sur le terrain la
qualité des interventions des sapeurs
pompiers des services de l'ordre de
l'état des collectivités territoriales
des villes et du département qui ont
porté rapidement secours à la population
je remercie également je suis remercié
allemand
ceux qui ont participé depuis et vous
êtes nombreux sur tous les bancs à avoir
participé à ce formidable élan de
solidarité
dimanche vous l'avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre le président de la
république est venu sur place
témoigner de sa solidarité nationale cet
événement climatique de l'avis de tous
les spécialistes est à la fois etc c'est
net et imprévisible dans sa violence et
sa rapidité
les communes concernées ont pourtant
fait ces dernières années des travaux
très importants pour lutter contre les
inondations dans un territoire exposé
ces phénomènes pourtant se reproduisent
et 100 leaf qui plutôt que de chercher
un bouc émissaire nous devons rendre si
monsieur le député la parole à monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur
à
terminer rapidement vos questions sur le
député nous devons améliorer nos
systèmes de prévention et aussi
réfléchir aux dérèglements climatiques
je vous demandons monsieur le premier
ministre quelle mesure l'état et le
gouvernement va prendre mettre en place
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur pour
remédier à ces problèmes et éviter ces
catastrophes
merci monsieur leonetti la parole à
monsieur miné de l'intérieur
oui monsieur le député léonetti vous
étiez présent avec le président de la
république et de nombreux élus eric
ciotti christian estrosi l'ensemble des
maires concernés dimanche lorsque nous
sommes rendus pour témoigner de la
solidarité de la nation et mobilité
aussi l'ensemble des services de l'état
qui sont intervenues pour que les
secours soient apportés pour que les
secours soient apportées dans les
meilleurs délais mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de bruit de ce côté là nous
avons donc décidé très rapidement de
délégués l'ensemble des moyens
nécessaires à la mise en oeuvre des
secours c'est ainsi que cinq cent
soixante trois sapeurs pompiers
accompagnés des marins pompiers de
marseille les militaires de la forme
east 300 policiers et gendarmes sont
intervenus aux côtés des pompiers dennis
dont vous avez eu raison de signaler
qu'ils avaient fait un travail
absolument remarquable il ya eu près de
1200 intervention il ya eu plus d'une
centaine d' opérations d'hélitreuillage
et les trois hélicoptères de la sécurité
civile et de la gendarmerie qui ont été
mobilisés et comme vous j'ai pu
constater la solidarité la solidarité de
toutes les collectivités locales la
solidarité nationale mais aussi
l'efficacité des services publics dans
leurs interventions
je veux en réponse à votre question
donner des éléments extrêmement précis
premièrement l'arrêté de catastrophe
naturelle sera présenté en conseil des
ministres demain publié jeudi
il permettra à l'indemnisation par les
compagnies d'assurances dans les
meilleurs délais des victimes
je rencontrerai au sortir des questions
d'actualité la fédération française des
compagnies d'assurance ainsi que
l'ensemble des administrations
concernées de manière à ce que l'on
puisse le plus rapidement possible
procéder à l'indemnisation j'ai demandé
à l'être et fait ça
de raccourcir au maximum les délais par
ailleurs nous avons décidé de mobiliser
le fonds qualité nationale pour faire en
sorte que les collectivités locales
soient le plus rapidement possible
mobilisés dans le cadre de la rénovation
des ouvrages d'art et pour ce qui
concerne les dispositifs de prévention
nous ferons des propositions dans
quelques jours au regard du retour
d'expérience du drame qui s'est produit
dans les alpes-maritimes cieux ministre
la parole à monsieur christophe castaner
monsieur le président